[Music]
what theme song is that from what movie
da da da da
no don't be real I done said I didn't
see the repeat after me oh no no what
movie is that from no no no is it
space-related
yes I know I can see it yeah mom mom
watch this yeah not star game yes
Independence Day I love that movie
welcome to Tiger belly I love that movie
so much so close can I have some trivia
for Independence Day okay tell me tell
me okay I'm gonna ask you some questions
okay in Independence Day Independence in
the movie Independence Day right and
it's diet yeah what one of what main
character died oh my god the wife of the
president yeah boy Lois all right let me
ask you this who plays this main
scientist in Airport and I am what's it
called Jerusalem area 51 the guy who
escorts the president in yeah yeah but
he's the main scientist down there can
you give me a clue he's in another
sci-fi show ah [ __ ] I know I see his
face brent Spiner
I wouldn't data from Star Trek there's
data from Star Trek died in the movie
yes how I don't know yes he does he dies
and the reason how he dies is it what
they have they you know I'm the black
guy what's his name
Will Smith yes the black eye right the
military black eye yeah okay so he was
an Air Force guy yeah and he was in
space not in space he was an air he was
in the air Liberia fighting no he was
fighting the aliens one of the aliens
right yeah and then the
what's a singer-songwriter with a singer
his friend he's a lounge singer or
something Harry Connick Harry Connick
what's his name Harry Connick jr. yeah
he's in it yeah he played his buddy
that's right Harry Connick dies they're
in this bass battle no their Arif air
battle and then and then the black guy
gets really angry yes the black guy
could use his name I refuse at this
point in the air with that space and
then he shoots one down I think
and then he he grabs one of the armed
aliens he punches him in the face
right he said have a nice day or
something yeah and punch him in the face
and he drags his alien yeah remember
that in a parachute yep and he gets
picked up by a Randy Quaid's brother yep
was that Dennis Quaid one of the Quaid's
the one who believes he got up does
whatever yeah yeah and then they make it
to the military base and then that one
alien um he's still alive could they did
surgery on him and then he came back
alive and then he took brent Spiner and
he killed that's how he died can I give
you guys another trivia well
Bobby actually auditioned for Aquaman
yeah and the reason why his audition
went really well is because they used
the same lines as Independence Day
didn't go well wait what you've
memorized every here's a why didn't go
well right because I first of all I love
Independence Day it's one of my favorite
movies I love everyone in it okay the
black guy yeah I love Jeff what's the
president's name in it Bill Pullman Bill
Pullman
Jeff Bill Pullman Vivica Fox
Vivica Fox hey Fox isn't it right that
black guy the lounge singer he's in it
right
the Quaid yeah data I love it data isn't
it but um the thing is is that I've seen
the movie so many times that it that the
audition for Aquaman was all the lines
from the movie Independence Day that the
scientists but as since I seen the movie
so many times that I did it at the same
exact way it didn't turn out I thought
if I were if I had it in the bag I would
I got the [ __ ] movie baby well I
think that if you
an independence day to audition yeah
yeah no but one of my dreams is to be in
a like a I love disaster movies that
everyone knows that right I've seen all
of them I've seen volcano yeah if you
can see volcano of course with Tommy Lee
Jones yeah it was a classic who plays
the woman in it that mean eh lezzy
erupted used to rub the vag with my
producer why did George know my producer
on pulling up together and Ellen
DeGeneres Majid they not and they
started a fire in West Hollywood years
ago
yeah good they rub so hard right it lit
up the [ __ ] town do you guys know
that though
I hope my boss doesn't hear what I just
said there but I don't want you to cut
it out okay all right because that's the
truth
[Music]